what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and the loki season finale was an oh so
satisfying one that not only gave us
og's of the kang gang big daddy kang
himself but also
finally explained the origins of the tva
and revealed that the mcu multiverse is
about to get seriously
kang banged but other than that massive
michael kangelo
statue of a cliffhanger one of the
biggest questions us nosy nerds of the
multiverse of madness want to know is
where the hell did this um teacher you
forgot the homework go
yeah i'm talking about you rent slayer
pushing owen wilson to the ground
how dare you he's a national treasure
but no seriously where does judge
ravonna renslayer even go when she walks
through this 10-pad door
in the loki season finale well my nerd
babies of the speculation nation i'm
speculating that ravona renslayer went
off to meet
the one and definitely not only kang the
conqueror
sort of okay as we see throughout the
loki series ravono rensselaer is a woman
who was deeply absorbed within the dogma
of the tva like this lady was so drunk
off of that tva
kang tang that she continues to believe
in the mission of the tva
even after learning that the timekeepers
were fake you know despite other tva
members like mobius hunter b-15 and
seemingly hunter u-92 in the finale
having the complete changes of heart
that normal non-crazy people tend to
have when they realize that they were
accidentally
fascist soldiers in a multiversal war
the entire time whoops
but not ravonna why is this well she
does give her ex bestie mobius and
moebius a reason for this in the loki
finale play the clip john the tva is a
lie but what if it's a necessary one
someone created the timekeepers i have
to believe
they had a reason you know what had
happened if we didn't prune the timeline
chaos death free will free will
only one person gets free will the one
in charge i believe that this quote from
ravona is an extremely important clue
that could point us to where she could
have disappeared to
because when moby is asked where she's
going the last thing that she says
before going to that yellow door of
mystery is
in search of free will because at the
root of it all rivona renslayer just
wants to be free like she wants to live
a normal life
so badly this is why she has so many
trinkets from past missions and why she
feels
genuinely betrayed by mobius siding with
a loki after what sounds like
millions upon millions of years of
friendship and when you take what
rentslayer says earlier in the series
friendship like ours is
uncommon it's safe to assume that mobius
was pretty much her
only friend in existence and this is
also why i believe renslayer has had a
secret side life as a principal
this entire time because as you see my
nerd babies in the finale hunter b-15
and hunter u-92
were in the year 2018 which just so
happens to be
the very same year thanos made the
entire universe
really annoying for people with dust
allergies like really annoying like
god couldn't get away from dust that
year i am of the strong belief that on
her
free time judge ravona renslayer has
been secretly living the life
of principal rebecca tormune during the
five years that principal torminae
was snapped away like hunter b-15 lured
hunter u92
and his squad to that moment in 2018 to
both illustrate that everyone in the tva
is a variant and show them rebecca
terminate
about to be snapped away eventually to
be replaced by a ravona rensselaer who
because she wants to be free and values
control as freedom pretends to be the
very person in charge of franklin d
roosevelt high school because
why wouldn't she that's literally
exactly in line with her character
in this scenario judge redslayer would
literally be working
for fun as a side thing with the last
name tormene obviously being a nod to
ren slayer's terminatrix personality in
the comics and if ren slayer is as much
of a hard ass as a principal as she is a
judge i would not be surprised if she
ends up being given the name
terminatrix by her actual students a
name that ravonna might actually end up
adopting in season two of loki but this
all being said
obviously the problem with rentslayer's
personal quest for freedom is that
rentslayer believes that you have to be
in control of everything
to truly be free and do you know who
else who knew this about rentslayer
he who remains because not only was he
aware of rentslayer's intense dedication
to order because he's the one who
elevated her to her position in the
first place but
he who remains also knew of her deep
desire for order on the cosmic
scale and that it would survive even the
revelation of the fake time keepers
themselves
because as it was revealed in the finale
that dang tang no arathang well you know
until about seven eight nine ten
seconds ago so up until then so you've
heard us talk about how helix mattresses
are customized to fit your specific
sleep needs well helix also makes
awesome furniture through their company
all four
all formless you customize the sofa
using premium materials at a fraction of
the cost of traditional stores you can
pick a fabric the color of the legs
sofa size and the shape to fit you and
your home which is very cool and they've
got everything from arm chairs to
eight-seat sectionals and new rockstars
editor john got a brown leather armchair
and ottoman from all former last year
that's a nice chair and he loves to
lounge in his super comfortable all-form
chair and think about
all those subliminal messages to slip
into our videos that he thinks that we
don't notice
but we do we do we always do john
i've been giving john two dollars a week
out of my savings account for months now
i don't know why i just feel this weird
compulsion just kidding that's that's
not even a lot of money
and all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home with fast and free
shipping and they'll get you your custom
furniture in just three to seven days
and you can assemble it yourself in just
a few minutes
no tools required and you get a hundred
days to decide if you want to keep it
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free
and give you a full refund which is
super dope and they'll even offer a
forever warranty like literally forever
like the third batman
movie like the warranty does not expire
but unlike the third batman movie it's
actually it's actually pretty good so to
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
new rockstars and all form is offering
20 off all
orders for our audience at allform.com
new rockstar so get to it all form
it's for you but remember when miss
minutes gives ravonna that data that she
totally didn't ask for in the finale
this isn't what i asked for
i know but he thinks this will be more
useful
who happy reading that data was
specifically given to her
by kang who remains himself data that i
believe to be the location
of young kang you know the kang from the
31st century earth
because again we learn in the finale
that kang who remains is very much
done with being in charge like he won
world war kang
he lived his million lifetimes as ruler
of the sacred timeline
and when we finally meet him he was
fully entirely bored and ready to be
done
with all of it just waiting waiting for
the right person to come along and take
him away from his life's work one way or
another like he was straight up willy
wonka in this but then
something happens then kang discovers
that his replacement wasn't just one
person
it came in the form of two loki's and in
particular
two loki's in love and so old man kang
is like
hey that's pretty good and so kang right
before he meets up with loki and silvie
decides to send rentslayer
a woman obsessed with the idea of
ordering control the time coordinates to
meet up with the very creator that she's
been searching for but a version of kang
a lot closer to the start of his quest
to conquer because
i firmly believe that loki season 1 is
just the beginning of the eventual
romance between ravona renslayer and
kang the conqueror and this is exactly
the person that she went to go see and
meet up with
in his native timeline of the 31st
century earth he who remains
is straight up trying to set a younger
version of himself
up with a partner dedicated to orders so
that he doesn't have to conquer the
multiverse alone because as king tells
us
he's tried to work with other versions
of himself in the past but that didn't
work out that's how the multiversal war
started so he
remains resolved to just be by himself
forever ever since then
because he's like you know what i can't
trust nobody if i can't trust myself but
unfortunately i do hear that eons and
eons of eating apples in an elevator at
the end of time by yourself really makes
you start to miss the warm touch
of a woman not me though i don't know
what that is
a woman women and so in summary when red
slayer says that she's in search of free
will in the loki finale i believe that
she is straight up chasing her own
glorious purpose the purpose of true
freedom through
control and little does she know that
she's on her way to meet and eventually
team up with the very man that she's
dedicated her life to
kang the conqueror and kang and
determinatrix are going to conquer and
bring order to this new multiverse of
madness together because in the comics
ravona
and kang have a very weird uh
extremely complicated relationship that
i could not even begin to explain
in this video because it's very strange
it's on again off again that's for sure
but
that's just my theory i want to hear
what my nerd babies of the speculation
nation
have to say where do you guys think red
slayer could have gone let me know
below but anyways thank you guys so much
for watching this video of course you
can follow me at mastertainment if you
want to see me tweet some weird but
most importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are especially on youtube
and when you do on youtube make sure you
hit that notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload a video
and also go to newrockstarsmerch.com so
you can pick up some dope shirts
like this shirt this is tva shirt but
most importantly our latest obsession
loki shirt that is not going to be
around forever please pick it up because
it's going to be pruned
from the timeline very soon kang is
coming he's coming for his shirts
pick up a shirt anyways thank you guys
so much for watching i love you guys
stay safe
see you later bye
[Music]
you